no el estilo para nosotros es en
realidad
nos vestimos así todos los días Así que
es realmente con diseñadores como Rick
Owens con los que aprendimos a hacer
nosotros mismos
y luego esta ropa nos dio la oportunidad
de expresarnos de forma natural también
así que para nosotros es realmente más
que un estilo
más que una estética es una forma de
vida
sin fondo
[Música]
recurrir a las colecciones de
diseñadores para saber quiénes somos y
cómo expresarlo Qué gran programa para
ello el californiano parisino Rick Owen
se inspiró en los trajes transparentes
que lucían los años 20 la primera del
cine mudo estadounidense vida vara
hoy se necesitan 200 metros de tul para
confeccionar estos vestidos pero tu
reciclado hecho con residuos capturados
en los océanos o recogidos de vertederos
esta colección se llama fdo en honor a
la ciudad egipcia que alberga el templo
de horus El Dios del cielo el hombre con
cabeza de Halcón
hay muchas cosas que podré ponerme Hola
cariño Cómo estás
Sí fue excelente
no sé qué decir cada vez
es increíble que haya una especie de
poesía que salga de todos estos
elementos
no sabemos y además de eso hicimos que
dejara de llover con nuestros grandes
chorros de agua
para seguir en esta línea un poco
alocada volvamos al colegio pero no a un
colegio cualquiera Ya que se trata del
prestigioso instituto parisino Ángel
cattle para conocer a una de las marcas
americanas más extremas niños ricos
deprimidos fundada en 2012 en Los
Ángeles por un hijo de muy buena familia
el sello entra dentro de la categoría
underground destroy
los modelos son unisex y los precios
increíbles como esta cuerda de Ahorcado
de cachemira vendida por 7000 euros un
truco de marketing una narración
extravagante en este sentido niños ricos
deprimidos es partidario del viejo
adagio solo porque no tengas nada que
decir no significa que debas callarte
tiene que tener la moda una finalidad
para mí es pura estética puramente
emocional puramente estética
no quiero molestarme en hablar de mi
trabajo porque es más emocional que
literal
es bonito o no lo es pero tiene sentido
y luego estoy muy cansado
he trabajado mucho en esta colección
gracias Gracias amigo
él también ha trabajado duro toda su
vida la mina y cuyatt 60 años para
celebrar el aniversario 30 de su marca
shulibeth desfila en plena calle a plena
luz del día sin música sin podio sin luz
fue en el Palace el primer desfile no
fue en el jardín de las tullerías que me
impresionó mucho ya sabe el desfile
blanco Antes había hecho uno en el
hospital efenea y se oto en el jardín de
las tullerías todo negro ya ves
ya ves el que realmente me marcó el que
es realmente la quinta esencia del
vestido blanco de hecho que celebramos
hoy que habíamos hecho en las tullerías
ya ves al aire libre con Las Chicas
armadas con pistolas del Ghetto
su padre se idubadia escritor y político
fue encarcelado en Mali su madre
ginecóloga estaba muy implicada en la
lucha contra la mutilación genital
nacido en una familia de siete hijos
varones la mismaté aprendió muy pronto
que nada debe desperdiciarse diseñador
de modo autodidacta empezó a finales de
los 80 con lo que aún no se llamaba
reciclaje con trajes impregnados de
cultura afroamericana desde entonces ha
viajado mucho a Mali senegal luego a
París Berlín y Nueva York hoy es un
hombre enfadado de todos modos en París
ya no pasa nada todos los lugares son
cuando uno pregunta en GT son 30 mil
dólares por una habitación individual
para hacer cualquier cosa quién va a
venir a hacerlo allí es decir paremos
están exagerando es decir no es posible
hablo por los jóvenes por los que vienen
detrás de nosotros quiero decir que la
cuestión es ésta tengo 60 años Tengo
hijos hablo por los que vienen detrás
Así que quiero decir que todo es
completamente es
que también estamos aquí para expresar
algo
y luego Eso significa abre los ojos
abramos los ojos a lo que está pasando
nada es neutro esto está claro pero creo
que podemos intentar convivir y no tener
a uno sentados en el banco viendo pasar
está enfadado No no estoy enfadado Pero
tenemos un enfado que es
bueno sí estamos enfadados hay rabia en
el mundo de hoy hay rabia Sí eso está
claro
[Aplausos]
Cómo se define el estilo de la minúyate
rock and roll
felino y alegría y belleza y amor sobre
todo hay amor detrás de sus creaciones y
la mina es amor siempre ha estado Con
todo el mundo humilde amable y eso se
nota en sus creaciones
la moda una gran forma de cuestionarnos
a nosotros mismos
si le encontramos sentido o no